we turn once again tonight to the crisis
that is on our southern border
even though the dha dhs secretary and
joe biden deny it
it's getting really really bad we have
10 cities we have coveted outbreaks
we have overflowing detention centers we
have dangerous cartels getting more
powerful now by the day
but the biden administration wants you
to believe there is no crisis whatsoever
however breaking tonight someone in the
administration
has now ordered a team of senior
officials to the border
to witness the crisis in person and as
we reported all week
emergency migrant shelters at the border
are
already operating at near full capacity
as of tuesday and this includes biden's
tents
biden's tarps then of course the tiny
cargo shipping containers that they have
bars on the tiny windows that's for kids
but don't worry they won't let you
inside to see it but they promise us
they put butterflies on the windows and
according to a new report from axios
tonight
the cdc is now allowing child
migrant shelters to expand beyond 100
capacity abandoning the requirement to
stay near 50 percent
because of covet now this has tens of
thousands of migrants
are expected at the border now just
weeks away
the dhs itself believes a record 117
000 unaccompanied minors will be coming
here
alone and will be intercepted now the
biden administration is eyeing
a site in the commonwealth of virginia
just south of richmond
at fort lee as a brand new shelter
for these unaccompanied minors as a part
of their plan to spread out
illegal immigrants all across the
continental u.s
and meanwhile just south of california a
tent city
filled with migrants has now grown to
over 1 000
people many of them are wearing biden
campaign
gear holding up signs please biden joe
let us in in less than 50 days in office
the border patrol has now totally been
subordinated
to illegal immigrants and deteriorated
under biden policies but is anybody
really surprised
biden promised to hand out amnesty to
illegal immigrants he's doing so
he vowed to increase asylum visas he
vowed to
stop and end all border wall
construction he's done that
people got their pink slips he has
ordered border patrol
to release illegal immigrants into
american cities
after they are processed which by the
way would be against sake
saying these policies are here to stay
take a look
go ahead thank you jen are there any
discussions within the white house
about reversing the policy of allowing
all unaccompanied children
in the united states no not at all
as this becomes a bigger disaster they
may want to circle back on that
open borders catch and release amnesty
all in the biden sanctuary states of
america
all in the middle of a pandemic and you
have the biden administration
bypassing laws of this land
abandoning the border patrol and opening
the floodgates
now we have dangerous cartels getting
rich through human trafficking we saw
that last weekend
in california drugs like oh you know 90
percent of the heroin in this country
fentanyl pouring across the border not
helping our opioid crisis
and now a massive humanitarian crisis is
looming
for all of us but the biden
administration won't even admit that
there is a problem
as president trump put it in a new
statement quote
the spiraling tsunami at the border is
overwhelming local communities
it is depleting budgets crowding
hospitals and
taking jobs from legal american workers
when i left office
well we had achieved the most secure
border in our country's history
under biden it will soon be worse
much worse more dangerous more out of
control than ever before
president trump is right and this week
our own sarah carter she has been
documenting all of this firsthand
last night after our show she went out
and obtained this exclusive footage
of at least one group of illegal
immigrants
yes attempting to enter this country
illegally
not abiding by our laws our borders and
our sovereignty